estas medidas violan libertades y
derechos de los ciudadanos a su decisión
de vacunarse o no vacunarse tal y como
está expuesto el documento los obliga a
vacunarse en algunos sectores de francia
fue calificado como una censura parcial
muy buenas noches y muchas gracias por
invitarme y la verdad es que yo no
considero que sea cierto esto por una
razón muy sencilla y es que primero las
libertades individuales siempre fueron
limitadas por el concepto del bien común
y el bien superior de la nación siempre
es es más importante que una decisión
personal segundo uno no se vacuna para
sí mismo porque podría decidir ya mí de
me da igual enfermarme sin embargo pues
no se vacuna para no contaminar a otras
personas que de pronto podrían ser más
vulnerables que otras entonces no me
parece que estén violando libertades hay
decenas de vacunas que forma obligatoria
es a través de la historia simplemente
esta es una reacción un poco caprichosa
frente a un momento de desconfianza
hacia las autoridades pero más que eso
me parece un falso debate señor murillo
vemos que el consejo constitucional no
aprobó ese apartado de la propuesta que
suspendía los contratos de trabajo para
las personas que no se vacunarán esto no
comenzará a generar problemas al
interior de las empresas al interior de
los mismos grupos de empleados de los
sindicatos entre quienes están vacunados
y quienes
están vacunados hay una cuestión
interesante aquí es que si uno no se
vacuna con el pase sanitario no tiene
acceso a ciertos lugares entonces de
alguna manera la sanción ya está
implícita y no debería en la época en
que la tecnología por lo general permite
trabajar a distancia salvo por empleos
manuales no debería vulnerarse el
derecho laboral de las personas porque
pues hay que encontrar un equilibrio
entre entre la digamos el bien común y
la necesidad individual en una persona
no vacunada que no tiene trabajo y que
se muere de hambre tampoco le sirve
mucho al país entonces se efectivamente
me parece irracional por parte de
espectar y del consejo constitucional
sabiendo que existen otros incentivos y
que si es obligatoria para salir pues
allí ahí termina la lección esta
decisión fue tomada en el marco del
avance que tiene la variante delta que
es la que está causando ahora la mayoría
de los casos alrededor del mundo el
gobierno francés teme tener picos como
los que tuvo el año pasado
o mejor dicho cuáles fueron estas
garantías que presentó el gobierno
francés para argumentar la necesidad de
imponer este pase sanitario como un
mecanismo digámoslo así para mitigar
entonces el impacto de la variante del
tae se está jugando el todo por el todo
con vacunación y pase sanitario pues
primero que todo esta situación se da
por mala gestión del gobierno desde el
principio entonces tenemos un una
disyuntiva importante y es que ellos
dijeron que nunca volverían la
vacunación obligatoria entonces tuvieron
que encontrar un artificio para para
poder ver la obligatoria como debería
ser al igual que el tétanos o que otras
enfermedades eso dicho en la garantía
pues básicamente hoy en día si no estoy
equivocado porque no soy epidemiólogo
pero el 90% de la gente que está en un
si es gente no vacunada y la variante
delta tiene una característica y es que
si bien no está prevista la vacuna para
defenderse de ella si limita digamos la
los daños que puede hacer y la ilimitada
digamos la hecho de que la gente termine
en situación grave o desde una versión
grave
eso limita a los variantes entonces eso
ya es de por sí es una garantía
importantísimo señor murillo que dejamos
de lado a los ciudadanos francesas que
están por fuera del país que están en
otras regiones del mundo que han
recibido vacunas como la vacuna hecha en
rusa en rusia o la vacuna china o
simplemente no han sido vacunados porque
son ciudadanos extranjeros no pueden
regresar a su país y no pueden acceder a
este pase sanitario como quedan entonces
los derechos y las garantías para los
ciudadanos franceses en el exterior
esto esto sí es una problemática que a
mí me toca particularmente yo tomé la
decisión de inmediato de solicitar a las
autoridades colombianas en caso de ser
vacunado que no me aplicaran sinovac por
no está reconocido por suerte no me tocó
esta vacuna sino otra
el caso es que normalmente habían
hablado de abrir la posibilidad del
turismo del turismo de vacunación
entonces hay una contradicción un poco
entre esta idea de abrir las fronteras
para que la gente pudiera ir a vacunarse
en francia y la idea de bloquear a las
personas en el exterior creo que las
medidas de cuarentena de persei de ide
ya son suficientes por decirlo